foreign
flyer myself who also experiences
intense flying anxiety I have developed
very specific emotional needs while in
the air
um now I've long since learned to
suppress my physical needs while flying
like like all other air Travelers I've
grown accustomed to being treated like
poultry stuffed in a cage and strapped
onto the back of a semi barreling down
the highway everything is cramped
there's no room to move around or
stretch your legs there's no concern for
your comfort on Spirit Airlines you know
the analogy becomes quite literal
because on spirit in particular the only
snack they give you and this is true is
they give you a handful of chicken feed
which the flight attendants toss in your
lap as they walk down the aisle scowling
at you of course if you if you eat the
chicken feed then it's an up charge of
43 dollars a person I think this is the
modern flying experience you sit there
miserable neglected squish between a
sumo wrestler and someone's emotional
support llama unless you fly first class
of course in which case you will enjoy
the decadent luxury of being treated
like a human being rather than livestock
In First Class you can engage in Wild
Flights of Fancy such as uh bending your
knee and moving your elbow
In First Class the flight attendants
will even mostly suppress their disdain
for you which is nice and there are
other perks too like in first class the
airline does you the favor of making
sure there's actually enough room in the
overhead compartment for the carry-on
baggage they said you could bring on the
plane as opposed to the coach experience
where half of the people have to check
their bags which they will likely never
see again
that's just how it goes and this is why
I have lowered my standards and reduced
my list of needs and expectations to
really just one item
and as it's an emotional thing for the
sake of my emotional well-being
I only ask that the flight attendants do
not appear visibly startled by
turbulence because even a slightly
raised eyebrow or a barely audible whoa
is to me a signal that we all face
certain death
so until today my point is that that was
that was the one meager favor that I
asked of the flight crew
but now it seems I must add one more
item to the list
because I also ask that the pilot does
not cross-dress while flying
I do not want to be an unwilling
participant in a drag show 35 000 feet
in the air
which is why I will certainly never fly
Virgin Atlantic not that I ever would
have flown them anyway to be fair but
here's the story from CNN it says Virgin
Atlantic has said that it is scrapping
gendered uniform options in an effort to
Champion the individuality of its
employees the British Airline announced
in a press release on Wednesday that
cabin crew pilots and ground staff can
select which uniform they feel most
comfortable in no matter their gender
gender identity or gender expression
optional pronoun badges will also become
available for for crew and passengers uh
Juha jarvanin whose Virgin Atlantic's
Chief commercial officer said in the
press release the company believes it's
important to encourage people to embrace
their individuality and be their true
selves at work
jarvanin added it is for that reason
that we want to allow our people to wear
the uniform that best suits them and how
they identify and ensure our customers
are addressed by their preferred
pronouns
now if this seems a bit unsettling to
you don't worry uh because CNN quote say
judge from RuPaul's Drag Race who says
that this is all a very good thing
and obviously there could be no better
Authority on proper standards of conduct
and air travel than a judge from
RuPaul's Drag Race
at least according to CNN quote myself
Visage who's a Michelle Visage a judge
on RuPaul's Drag Race All-Stars who
showcased the uniform alongside staff
welcome the move quote as the mother of
a non-binary child and as an ally to the
lgbtq plus Community these efforts by
Virgin Atlantic to further inclusivity
for its people are extremely important
and personal to me she said in the press
release people feel empowered when
they're wearing what best represents
them and this gender identity policy
allows people to embrace who they are
and bring their full selves to work
Virgin Atlantic said the changes are
part of a wider initiative under its be
yourself agenda
well this is great you know especially
when coupled with the news from earlier
in the year that airlines are lowering
their recruiting requirements for Pilots
so as to create a more diverse and
Equitable Workforce so what that means
is that you're racially diverse
genderqueer pansexual drag queen pilot
who goes by the name Captain hot pants
or something may not be the best
equipped to fly the aircraft but at
least he's being himself
so you can
[Music]
here's the here's the commercial by the
way let's just pause and watch this
commercial this is an airline commercial
[Music]
like you watch this and tell me you want
to fly this Airline this is what you
want
[Music]
Virgin Atlantic see the world
differently well they certainly are
delivering on that prop Pro promise
anyway
as you're as you know you can take
comfort at least as your uh
plain as nose diving into the Pacific
you can take comfort in the fact that
your pilot lived by his truth and now
he's dying by it and he's taking all of
you with him which is which is really an
honor I guess
now I'm only being slightly facetious
here I actually do appreciate this move
by Virgin Atlantic for two reasons okay
so for one thing
if the if the captain of my plane is
emotionally and mentally unstable I want
to know that ahead of time I actually
want him to advertise that and there's
no better way for him to advertise it
than by dressing in Drag
of course this only works to the
passenger's Advantage if the pilot
announces it prior to departure and if
the passengers who value their lives are
then given an opportunity to de-board
so it sounds something like this like hi
folks from the flight deck this is your
captain speaking I will be taking off in
about 10 minutes after a short taxi down
the runway also I am personally wearing
a skirt for this evening's flight uh my
father didn't love me and so this is
what I'm doing now I'll tell you more
about it when we're in the air thanks
for flying with us
so if there was an announcement like
that I mean it could work out to
everybody's Advantage but I don't think
that's how it will work on Virgin
Atlantic so I suppose this potential
positive is negated but there is still
this
that the whole stunt exposes the utter
inanity and absurdity of the left's
notion of individuality
because first of all this is not really
individuality at all when a man
cross-dresses he is not inventing a new
style or doing something nobody's ever
done before he is rather embracing a
different style one that is ugly and
disordered but he didn't create it this
is not something that originates in the
depths of his being it originates in the
culture the culture has told him that
this is a fashionable Brave laudable way
to dress and behave he is in fact
conforming
this is why you'll notice that drag
queens though they are supposed to be
fierce individualists all end up looking
exactly the same it's almost like
there's a drag queen uniform which
happens to be modeled after early 90s
Tim Burton films for whatever reason
this is true too of of people who
Endeavor to be non-binary or androgynous
in their style of dress they all end up
looking the same right right down to the
hairstyle and the facial piercings
there there is a much much greater and
more vibrant and interesting variety of
styles among men who dress like men and
women who dress like women than there
are among men and women who Endeavor to
break through these binary categories
they all end up looking like clones
created in the back of a Hot Topic or
something
second
even though all of this be yourself
stuff is basically a sham
and modern culture's notion of an
individual is far more rigid and
restricting than ever
we also see here why individuality and
being oneself are not the ideal in every
situation or even in most situations
because to be an adult in a civilized
society means controlling your impulses
and conforming yourself to certain
standards of conduct
as you go about your day you find
yourself in different roles you know all
kinds of roles as employee as customer
as neighbor as parent as spouse some of
these roles are situational some endure
and maintain every day all day through
your whole life but each role is
accompanied by expectations and
responsibilities
things you're supposed to do and not do
say and not say whether you like it or
not
so you uh bring your full self into each
role in a physical and literal sense but
there may be aspects of your personality
okay there may be um inclinations or
preferences or predilections you have
which are not appropriate and should not
be expressed or engaged in given the
role or circumstance
so if you walk through life declaring
that you're going to be yourself
everywhere all the time meaning that
you'll simply do whatever you want not
respecting any standards or
acknowledging any expectations that
everything in your life quickly breaks
down
and you begin to fail in every role and
thus in life itself
nowhere could this be more obvious than
in the context of air travel
because when we are in a metal tube 35
000 feet in the air hurtling along at
600 miles an hour
it isn't the place for anyone to be
their true selves or Express themselves
individually
nobody like I don't want anyone on the
plane doing that
given the stakes and the consequences if
things go wrong and given that we're all
stuck in close proximity to each other
and that none of us can immediately exit
the situation without suffering rather
significant consequences
um an airplane is then a place for
decorum and professionalism
I want very little personal expression
from the person sitting next to me even
less do I want it from the pilot
none of us are on the plane in order so
that we can get to know the captain on
an intimate and personal level none of
us are interested in his true self
that's not why we pay exorbitant sums to
board the aircraft
we don't want the pilot to express
himself we want him to express the plane
from point A to point B and that's it
we simply want to arrive at our
destination
we want the flight crew to get us there
as quickly and safely as possible and
with little as little drama as possible
I'm flamboyant individualism has never
kept a plane in the sky
engineering and physics is what keeps
the plane in the sky along with the
expertise of professionalism on the part
of the people in the cockpit
so that should be the focus
and I shouldn't have to say this but
this is also why you should not be
cross-dressing while flying the plane
that is also why Virgin Atlantic is
today canceled that'll do it for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]